when did you begin to drink urine and do
you drink only your own urine or do you
drink other peoples as well
um I drink my own urine brother and
again I did I started this nearly 24
years ago I heard
um a medical doctor talk about this and
I'm like that guy's a crazy nut and then
I heard David avocado woof avocado
David avocado wolf is a good friend of
mine and I heard him talk about it and
David's a little out there but I trust
the man and then I heard a third medical
doctor talk about it and I I I like
everybody I believes that you should
trust your lord and savior and test and
prove all things brother not some things
but all things and I'm like really Lord
I gotta really test and prove piss and I
began to do the research and I got the
book your own perfect Medicine by Martha
Christie and I read through that book
and I'm like oh my goodness brother this
could be real
um and again this is liquid go